private security forces helping enhance
Security on the Las Vegas Strip one of
those forces is expanding Brian will
shares what they have to go through
before they become the security you see
in the strip and throughout the valley
last man just your attention
bill norvel is a 10-year military
veteran and former SWAT team member he
leads this training of private security
officer candidates Peter 5's EST teams
respond to open areas near the casinos
with the casinos so they're ability to
respond to an active threat quickly
effectively and efficiently is Paramount
to the instruction here on my last on my
left or right door right all right all
right they are sometimes the first line
of defense to critical incidents Jordan
willmeth is one of the candidates
training to join a team we're the
initial response before law enforcement
gets there so that's allowing us to
secure a scene or you know have a little
bit better play when law enforcement
does come into the scene these security
officers are going through their final
day of training and they're practicing
clearing the hallway for an active duty
threat
last minute we've been able to graduate
successfully three classes in each of
the classes unfortunately did have
washouts so there is a standard that
needs to be met by the teams that
standard according to Jonathan Alvarez
with protective Force International
includes a psych evaluation defense
tactics Firearms qualifications and
their final exercise here this isn't the
end of their training each month they're
still training on a specific topic and
then they're tested on that topic for
continuous training the more I can help
law enforcement and the community that's
what we're here for
this class of candidates graduate
tonight will soon be working with
casinos and area law enforcement of
course to keep you safe